If you haven't noticed
at the back of my addition
of Douglass's narrative,
which is the one I am
hoping you are using,
come on down in quickly.
Anyway,
if you haven't noticed at the back of
this edition of Douglass's narrative,
they're not only,
okay
a variety of ancillary documents.
Douglas is greatest
speech was also included
a word on that. It's Douglas is 4th of
July speech. If you've never read it,
you should read it.
It is the rhetorical masterpiece
of American abolitionism,
one of the greatest works of
Oratory and American history.
It was Frederick Douglass
as Beethoven on steroids,
but with language,
it's like a symphony in three movements.
I say that in a little
headnote introduction to it.
He gave that speech in 1852 I may
refer to it at the end of this lecture,
depending on the time
it is all about the crisis that has
gripped the country in the wake of the
compromise of 1850 in the midst of this
expansion of slavery into the West and
the way it has begun to tear
apart America's political culture,
and on the 4th of July I missed
his friends in Rochester,
New York. He was invited to
give the 4th of July oration.
He says,
thank you very much.
The invitation was from the ladies
in antislavery society of Rochester,
New York,
many of whom were his friends.
He gave the address in the house of his
friends, Corinthian Hall and Rochester,
600 people in the audience.
Double more than double your numbers.
Read that speech because
it's as if Douglas,
after that first opening
gentle introduction where
he sets his audience at ease
about the greatness of
the founding fathers,
the genius of the
Declaration of independence.
He calls it the ring bolt
of American independence,
the ring bolt of American identity.
He just makes them feel
good about the founders.
And then it's as if he has a staff
bolting doors around the hall.
And then he's got a staff
riveting people into their seats,
puts metaphorical
seatbelt on him and says,
you won't move until I rain.
Held on on you for the next 20 minutes,
which is what he did.
And he says, in effect,
he says more than in effect.
He says it directly,
why have you invited me speak
to you on your 4th of July?
And then it just rains the
pronouns on them. You, you,
you, you, your, your, your,
your 4th of July is yours and not mine.
You may rejoice.
I us mourn and 90 90 goals.
And then there's the moment,
one of the most brilliant rhetorical
moments in American letters in my view,
but certainly an abolitionist writings
where he doesn't even announced his texts
to his well rooted biblical audience.
And he says,
after raining down on them,
this passage as long passage
about the 4th of July is yours.
You may rejoice imas mourn to drag
a man and he fetters into the grand
illuminated temple of liberty.
And call upon him to join you.
Enjoy his anthems is in human.
Mockeries says,
and then he just floats without
announcing his text and does 137 song
and he's simply reads
by the rivers of Babylon.
There we sat down. Yay. We
wept when we remembered Zion.
We hanged our harps upon the willows
in the midst of their, uh, for their,
they that carried us away captive required
of us a song and they who wasted us
required of US mirth saying,
sing us one of the songs of Zion.
How can we sing the Lord's
song in a strange land?
If I forget the Old Jerusalem, but
my right hand, forget her cunning.
If I do not remember the but my
tongue cleave to the roof of my mouth.
What does Douglas just done
to his friendly audience?
He just, one of the most
famous passages in the Bible,
his audience would have
known that passage.
People wouldn't today in little
circles by the rivers of Babylon.
There we sat down, we were the
captives from Egypt and he said,
you made us sing for you.
And in effect,
he was saying to them,
I'll sing for you,
but you may not like it.
That was Douglas as you did it
hundreds of times elsewhere.
It was Douglas is most
brilliant expression of,
or critique of this American hypocrisy
about freedom in a land of slavery,
but a lot of people were worried
about this contradiction.
It was Douglas as well in
the midst of the Mexican war,
which is what we're about today in 1847
myths are that expansionist war where at
least modest numbers of northerners,
certainly abolitionist opposed it because
they saw it as a war for the expansion
of slavery.
It was Douglas who said,
America is a nation of in consistencies,
completely made up of
it's in consistencies.
Do you know the young Abraham Lincoln
had always been worried about this?
Very same question.
He comes at it from different perspective.
He comes out of from
different experiences largely.
Yeah,
he's never going to be an abolitionist,
but it is very first public address.
The young men's lyceum speech of 1838
the first public address that a young
Abraham Lincoln ever gave in the middle
of it is this quite remarkable passage
where it says though he's
almost predicting we don't
want to him too much credit
for his predictions,
but it's almost as if he's predicting
this crisis that we're now about to try to
understand for the next several weeks.
At what point said Lincoln in this speech
way back in 1838 at what points shall
we expect,
the approach of danger,
by what means shall we fortify against it,
shall we expect we hear
is this American nation?
Shall we expect some transatlantic
military giant to step over the ocean and
crush us at a blow?
He answers never.
All the armies of Europe,
Asia,
and Africa combined with all the treasure
of the earth could not by force take a
drink from the Ohio river or make a track
on the Blue Ridge mountains in a trial
of a thousand years.
If destruction is to be our lot,
we must ourselves be its author and
it's finisher is a nation of free men.
We must live through all
time or die by suicide.
He doesn't say what that
problem in the midst would be
directly.
It's already implied it.
What is civil war?
What a kind of collective suicide.
No,
briefly,
and I'm going to put the underground
railroad story off until after we do the
aftermath and collapse of
the compromise of 1850 oh,
I just predicted it would collapse.
Sorry about that.
But this antislavery
impulse that does take hold,
and the American north went
through various stages.
That first stage is the 1830s
into the 1840 [inaudible],
which is largely a time of great expansion
and abolition as organizations and
societies and newspapers. It tends
to be a decade, decade and a half,
driven largely by a kind of Garrisonians
and I outline the various tenants of
Gareth and isn't,
but it tended to be a kind of
Gareth Sonian moral suasion.
This was an era in which most
abolitionists were largely
devoted to this idea of
reforming or changing the heart
of the American people. This was,
this was driven very much by the kind
of evangelical second grade awakening
impulse of changing the conscience.
Oh, the American people indeed just
changing the conscious of the slave holder
himself.
Okay.
A second stage of American
antislavery impulse. It's not,
there's no single moment when it begins,
but that second stage is
essentially a political stage.
It begins largely with the birth of the
Liberty Party as it was called an 1837
the first attempt at an antislavery
political party founded by some pretty
serious abolitionists. These were, these
were, these people were the real thing.
They're going to run James G Bernie for
president a couple of times and they got
minuscule numbers of almost
comfortable votes. James G,
Bernie,
who had been born in Alabama,
former slave holder who moves
north and becomes an abolitionist.
His symbol was quite remarkable
that liberty party will
morph in the 1840s after
its record of very little success into,
especially in the midst
of this Mexican war,
what became known as the free soil party
play 848 and we'll pick up the free
soil is here in a few minutes.
The free soil party as it was founded
in 1848 directly in response to this
expansion.
This war with Mexico was a party largely
devoted by its very title to keeping
the West free of slavery,
it political impulse to try
to keep America's future
free of slave labor system.
But what's really going on here is
a shift out of the moral suasion,
just impulses of early abolitionist
to a learning of the art of politics.
Yeah.
I've engaging a larger culture
with the nation's greatest issues,
and it is of course when abolitionism
or an antislavery impulse is what I want
to call it here because this isn't these,
these are not necessarily
rabid abolitionists to
become free soilers and Nora
Nora who become the Republican's
after 854 but it is a fear of slavery,
of fear, of it's power, of fear of
it's a denigration of free labor,
a fear of the way slavery as a system
could control America's future.
The becomes a special in the wake
of the Mexican war front and center,
the greatest political issue in America.
Okay,
well how did we get a Mexican war?
Now,
I don't know if you know much
about the war with Mexico.
We speed right over it and a
lot of American history classes,
but after the annexation
time for some maps,
uh,
I think that does a bull mostly
well
after the annexation of
Cuba in 18 third as Cuba,
Texas in 1836 the south was always trying
to annex Cuba four times before the
civil war.
I can't get that out of my head,
but after the annexation of
Texas by the United States,
Texas became a state.
So said the United
States after eight and 36
okay.
Texas was to be that great western
territory, seemingly limitless.
It's western border had never
been determined for that matter.
A southern border with Mexico had
never been negotiated. You know, he's,
today's just took Texas and said,
wow,
we'll figure out its boundaries
later. Oh, by the way,
Mexico will let them know.
Mexico never accepted the Rio Grande
as a border between United States and
Mexico.
Never.
They assumed if there was a border with
this first independent republic of Texas
and now state of Texas,
it was to be the Nueces river.
Can you see the Nueces river? Not
very visible, but it's up here.
My hands not to steady anyway,
the Rio Grande was never
accepted as the border by Mexico,
but that's never stopped.
Wars of conquest before.
And why would it then
now,
just to give you a bigger
sense of this store, uh,
we've already talked a lot about how the
westward expansion of a slave society
in the westward expansion of the south
was just booming from the 1820s to the,
into the 14th and there was a deep
and abiding assumption in America.
We call it manifest destiny.
At the time,
not everybody was walking around
mouthing the phrase manifest destiny.
People didn't meet in bars and
taverns and say, what do you think?
Manifest destiny?
But they spoke a language of um,
inevitability.
They spoke a kind of racialism
about what needs to be done,
should be done,
has been done about Indians and the Indian
removal policies under Jackson of the
1830s. Did indeed of course
remove Indian removal.
I have a whole map of that.
I love my maps.
This one's cool,
but of course it's a brutal story.
The five great tribes some times called
the civilized tribes of the American
south, the creeks, the
Chickasaw, the Choctaw,
the Cherokee,
and the Seminole from Florida.
We're indeed between the early 1830s
in the mid to late 1830s remove by and
large,
not all of the Seminoles,
but remove it out west to what became
Oklahoma territory or was originally
called Indian territory.
But that Indian removal was in great.
There's part and parcel of opening up
this southern frontier to expansion into
the possibilities now of the cotton boom
and the development of the greatest,
as we've said, no more than once.
Source of wealth in the United States.
No, the presidential election
of 1844, James K. Dot. Polk,
the Democrat,
um,
kind of hard money
successor to Andrew Jackson,
avid expansionist and a slave
owning cotton planner from Tennessee
got elected president. They called him
young and Hickory instead of old hickory.
He ran against Henry Clay who ran for
president three, four or five times,
depending on how many times you count
them in the antebellum years as well.
Daniel Webster,
the Henry Clay,
essentially the intellectual
or ideological founder of
the Whig party ran is the
wig,
uh,
clay to ran on an expansion as
platform of a car of a kind,
but the winds tended to argue for
expansion isn't by negotiation.
We were going to negotiate
treaties of experience.
our way into the southwest.
We were going to negotiate the
British out of the northwest.
Polk said,
negotiation
bullshit is what he said.
Elect me and I will give you a Mexico
elect me and I will give you Oregon.
He did.
It was a close election,
poke one by only about 36,000
votes out about 2.8 million cast.
Yeah.
He barely won New York state democratic
stronghold in part because of
immigration to New York and he carried,
therefore New York's 36 electoral votes
and was elected the Liberty Party of
James G.
Bernie got 16,000 votes in 1844 most of
them and about three counties in upstate
New York. They didn't cause a
lot of Ruckus, but they existed
now just before Tyler,
John Tyler left office as a lame duck,
he pushed through the
annexation of Texas as a state,
not as a negotiated treaty, which
would have required as I hope you know,
two thirds vote of the US Senate.
He just did it.
Okay.
And Texas was annexed.
Now, Congress eventually,
uh, did vote approval of this
in a frankly sectionalized vote,
which was a harbinger of things
to come. But James K. Polk,
this expansion as president expansion,
the slave holding president now became
the sixth of the first 10 American
presidents who was a slave holder.
This is significant if you'll actually
look back, there's a great book on this,
the demonstrators, lots of
writing on this, a demonstration,
but don Fehrenbach or his book
called slave holding republic,
shows us that before
the American civil war,
two thirds of all American presidents
were slave holders or deeply sympathetic
with slave holding.
As in the case of James Buchanan,
by the late 1850s,
two thirds of all members of the u
s supreme court were slave holders.
And so far as we know, James K. Dot.
Polk was the only president in American
history to actually buy and sell slaves
from the Oval Office of the White House.
Okay.
He kept on retainer,
a broker with whom he communicated
regularly buying and selling, slice,
speculating and slaves.
It was kind of his hobby.
You know, some presidents engage in the
hot stove league in the winter, you know,
do some baseball and paper poke
was selling and buying and people,
yeah.
Poke who was aggressive toward Mexico.
He ordered American troops demarche
south to the Rio Grande River in Texas.
There were, were already, you know,
occupy patient troops in Texas.
He ordered the middle of south of the Rio
Grande and just in effect see what the
Mexicans would do.
Yeah.
Any sense?
Zachary Taylor,
the American general to matter Mauras
on the Mexico border in early 1846 there
was a negotiation initially set up
between the American and Mexican military
commanders,
which was conducted by the way in French
because of the Americans did not speak
Spanish and the Mexicans
did not speak English,
but they find enough people on either
side of good to understand at least some
French.
Yeah,
Mexico had never
acknowledged the Rio Grande.
It said their border was the
nooses north about 150 200 miles.
That was a kind of a three weeks standoff
between troops along the Rio Grande
River.
And then on the 24th of April,
1846 a Mexican cavalry contingent,
ambushed American troops on the
north side of the Rio Grande killed,
killed 11 American troops captured 63
two days later,
Zachary Taylor,
a dispatch overland to Washington DC.
It took two weeks to get their hot news
and it simply announced,
quote, hostilities had
been commenced with Mexico.
Briefly told the story of the Mexicans
attacking on the north side of the Rio
Grande.
Polk receive the news and he immediately
went to Congress and ask for a
declaration of war. He announced, quote,
Mexico had passed the boundary of
the United States and had invaded our
territory and shut American
blood on American soil unquote
blood and soil.
I May,
1318 46 the house of Representatives
voted a declaration of war 174 to 14 u s
senate voted 40 to two with
a lot of abstentions from
northerners to declare war
on Mexico
and off we went.
The first major expansionist
war of American history,
war fever broke out all over the country.
The romance of going abroad
and exotic place like Mexico,
full of strange people speaking in weird
languages and they're Catholics and
you'll never know what
you're going to find there.
They all kinds of strange practices.
Herman Melville,
the young writer and
yet published Moby Dick,
but he was working on it from
is upstate New York home.
He said in his tone that people here,
he said, are all in a state of delirium,
a military art or pervades all ranks.
Nothing is talked about,
but the halls of Montezuma,
meaning Mexico City,
this was going to be an adventurous war.
It was going to be quick.
It was going to be a war of a destiny
in Illinois.
Newspaper justify the war on
the basis that Mexicans were,
I quote reptiles in the
path of progressive.
Now, you know, in Vietnam we called
some people goofs and you know,
they were doing that horrible huns and
we've got all kinds of names for our
enemies, but then they will
get more direct than that.
Reptiles and I'm sorry.
Reptiles in the path of
progressive democracy. Yes. Well,
uh,
people rewrote the lyrics to the song,
Yankee doodle to fit the Mexican
war went like this. I promise you.
Only one verse.
They attacked our men upon our
land and crossed our river to sir.
No. Show them all with a sword
in hand. What Yankee boys can do.
Booster, I'm sorry, I have a cold.
Oh,
actually you should
do that with an Irish brogue because
that's the way it would have been done.
Then making fun of the Irish while
you make fun of the Mexicans while you
recruit the Irish to go fight in Mexico.
Many abolition is tat very serious
things to say about this war.
Lots of them. I already mentioned
Douglas and many, many others.
The abolitionists,
James Russell Lowell considered the war,
his words and national crime
committed in booth of slavery.
Our common sin and most pointedly of all,
and a title for this lecture was
Ralph Waldo Emerson. As usual.
Emerson wrote this into his private
journals from his study and conquered.
It wasn't no something, too many public
platforms on this one, at least not yet.
Emerson wrote into his journals in
early 847 the United States will conquer
Mexico, he said, but it will be
as though a man swallows arsenic.
Okay.
Which brings him down in
term Mexico will poison us.
It did. Um, by the end of 1846,
the u s had established dominion
over the southern half of California,
which Mexico also claimed
1847.
United States forces in the face of pretty
ferocious resistance invading largely
through Vera Cruz on the Gulf coast.
But also from the north
conquered Mexico City,
the halls of Montezuma,
hence the line in the Marine Him
United States lost 13,000 Americans in
the war with Mexico and about a year and
a half of fighting
by far the vast majority died
of disease and not in battle.
An estimated 50,000 Americans
died.
Okay.
The sword and the Canon
of American troops.
Okay.
And by the end of the United States
negotiated a treaty with Mexico.
We conquered them and we dictated the
terms and the terms that everything to do
with American geography.
The Mexican cession as it became known,
the land the United States gained from
Mexico is of course the whole southwest.
Okay.
In the treaty of Guadalupe Hidalgo of 1848
United States obtained what is today
all of the western part of Texas, New
Mexico, Arizona, southern California,
all of California, uh,
Utah. Parts of Colorado,
Nevada,
the great southwest.
Yeah.
That same year,
yeah.
Was a terribly important year
of turning point in the world,
especially in Europe.
There are those arguing now that in
some ways 1848 should be as important a
turning point year in American history
as it is in Europe because of the great
democratic Republican
revolutions in Europe. Uh,
there are debates now and
some history departments,
whether the U S survey courses
should be divided in thirds now,
cause since American histories
into the 21st century,
now it's getting too long as countries,
it's got too much history
now and instead of dividing,
our survey of course is at 1840
at 1877 or 865 it should be 48
who cares?
But
as these nationalistic
revolutions against monarchy,
we're breaking out all over
Europe in Hungary, Austria,
Italy, Germany, France,
some will succeed in established republic,
some will not.
Republican America
was seizing territory and launching
an empire and its own continent.
Okay.
Oh by the way,
for seeding us,
all of that territory of the great
southwest Mexico was paid $15 million.
Okay.
Sitting in the US House of Representatives
at that very time during the Mexican
war in his only two term,
two year term US Congress was a young
congressman from Illinois named Abraham
Lincoln. He voted against the
Mexican war. Every chance he got,
he opposed it.
He called it pokes war
and then
he said,
pokes justification.
These are the days of
direct political language.
Is it pokes justification for the war?
Was Ha a half insane
mumbling of a fever dream?
Tell him aid
mince any words, fever, dream.
All right,
but what are the Mexican war on leash?
What are the legacies of the Mexican war?
Why was this such a fuss and the outline?
It says,
why all the fuss slavery in the
Western territory who cared?
Daniel Webster, who will play a big
role in this compromise of 1850 debate,
the great wig of Massachusetts,
probably the most powerful
and important northern,
certainly New England politician
kept warning that this was,
it wasn't all that important.
He said the problem of slavery
in the West is like his quote is,
is a big fuss over quote an imaginary
Negro in an impossible place.
And the idea there wasn't
all that Southwire. It's all
desert, isn't it? I mean,
what's, what's the problem? It's
not Louisiana in New Mexico.
It's not Alabama in Arizona.
Cotton wool boom. There he
called it a mere abstraction.
But if it was a mere abstraction,
why did so many people care?
Let's examine this just for a moment.
Why the fuss? First northerners,
and I know I'm generalizing here,
there's no thing, there's no,
there's no such thing as the north
and thus south at this point.
I hope you've grasped that there are
complexities within, but to northerners,
one that cared about this because there
was the belief that slavery could indeed
take root in the southwest.
Why wouldn't it be a perfect environment
for mining of silver and gold?
And Lo and behold,
right after the treaty of Guadalupe
Hidalgo and the end of the Mexican war,
what happened,
gold was discovered in California
and it just capitalize.
It just made all bets off.
Now on just how important
this question might be,
why wouldn't slavery worked for
the building of the railroad?
Why wouldn't slavery worked for
building canal and for that matter,
nobody wanted to compete with the slave
labor system cause it denigrated or
degraded the ID of free labor.
Secondly,
there were a lot of
northerners particularly in
in politics who wanted a Nanex
who favored here a non
extension approach to slavery,
whatever they thought of black people
and the future of their rights and the ID
of any kind of racial equality.
They favorite non extension
on constitutional grounds.
The idea was that those who would not
attack slavery where it already existed
because slavery slaves were property
and protected by the amendment.
They nevertheless believe they could use
the constitution under Congress's sole
authority to admit new
states to the union.
Just stop this system from expanding
to stop America's future from becoming
defined by slave labor rather than
free labor for the little man.
Nine extension of slavery therefore became
a kind of idea whereby you could cold
NOFX slavery and blunt it's future
three for northerners bills in Congress
for the territorial organization which
already existed.
Now as soon as the Mexican war,
before the Mexican war was even over,
there were bills before Congress to
establish the territory's now of Utah and
New Mexico. No, in in
large swaths of land.
Mind you that could become
more than two states
and there were northerners who found these
bills simply personally obnoxious and
they were being asked.
They said to be complicit to us.
Now in the expansion of slavery,
they there was,
there were known enough northern
politicians just said, look,
I can't stop anything that's going on
in Alabama and I won't try but don't ask
me to vote to create a new territory
that will become a slave state
and already in the language of the
free soil party and eventually in that
Republican party that will come out of
it is this idea that what northerners had
to work to do,
they said what's to make
slavery sectional but freedom,
national slave labor,
sectional regional bound
to a place but free labor,
national eternal and the
definition of a future.
Yeah.
It was also racism as a motive in this.
There are a lots of northerners who saw
the West is the hope of the northern
immigrant,
the hope of the young farmer in Ohio
who's got three sons and they want to go
west and I don't want,
they don't want black people around.
They want to Kansas or Nebraska eventually
that's free for small white farmers
and that's rooted of course.
And what we're going to come
back to again and again,
the next three four lectures as this
idea of a kind of a free labor ideology,
a cluster of ideas, no single
idea, but a cluster of impulses,
assumptions,
ideas,
one of which was defensive representative
government has other voice,
wasn't devotion to individual
liberty for small people,
small farmers,
loan mechanics coupled with no fear of
concentrated power and what could be more
concentrated form of power and an
oligarchy of slave holders who can lo and
behold, control of the presidency, the
Supreme Court and enough of Congress,
especially the Senate, if they can keep
getting more states into the union,
then the south as a concentrated power
free labor ideology.
It was also rooted in this kind of now
old fashioned American fear of conspiracy
against individual liberty,
free labor on you know how old he was
really a fanfare for the common man,
defensive,
the white Anglo Saxon Protestant,
small farmer.
And of course finally there were some
real abolitionists in the room who oppose
the expansion of slavery on moral grounds
and sometimes that
person who believes in free Labor ideology
and may not want it too many black
folks around also takes a kind of moral
position against slavery all at the same
time.
And His name was Abraham
Lincoln. No, in the south.
Why the south care about slavery in the
West in part because in an assumption
it's set in among southern
leadership now for a long time
that it was not only the destiny of
the American people to expand west,
it was only the destiny of the slave
society does it spray spraying west and
remember there are manufacturing
decade by decade and more intensive
justification of this system,
but it was a necessity.
They're going to argue that it expand or
it would die to check the expansion of
slavery would be to strangle the southern
economy and way of life is what so
many southern politicians are now
arguing slaves in existing states.
Also, they came to realize
we're becoming a burden,
possibly a danger as the slave
population in Georgia or in Alabama or
Mississippi continues to grow
and grow and grow and grow,
but nowhere to expand to
that's my population may be
coming, dude. A powder keg.
Yeah.
One of the things that southern
statesman feared the most,
and I cannot stress this enough because
there's going to be right there at the
heart of their succession debates in 1860
is they feared what they kept calling.
Now, this is more than a theory to
them, this theory of a shrinking south.
If they couldn't expand the system
beyond its limits and beyond its borders,
get into Arkansas, get out in
Oklahoma, Texas, West Texas,
further west Caribbean.
Yeah.
At the south would begin to
shrink as an economic entity,
as a political culture,
as a force in the national government,
and if you cordoned off slavery,
what's going to happen to the price
of slaves around it's borders?
They might be going to go down and what
happens with the price of a slave starts
going down in Kentucky, Virginia,
Maryland, around the edges.
Well, people start selling them off. We're
going to sell them Alabama, Louisiana,
Mississippi,
and you would have the beginnings now
have an economy turning in on itself.
Okay?
Southerners,
many southerners came to believe
slavery had to expand or it could die.
They also want to political parody
in the United States Congress,
every new statement to new
senators and the number of states,
free states,
the slave states folks
in 1850 was 15 to 15
they wanted to sustain that
parody and California there is,
it's going to sudden statehood in 1850
because of gold being discovered is going
to be the problem and the test case,
the newest,
this question of a constitutional power.
Yeah,
the question of checks and balances. The
states' rights question if you weren't,
did anybody have the right
to PR to prohibit anybody
from taking their property
anywhere? The John C. Calhoun,
at the end of the day,
all these other arguments
here were important,
but the only argument at the end of the
day that mattered to him and he could
drive it home with a brilliance unlike
anybody else's. You have no right.
You northerners have no right
to stop me from taking my wagon,
my horse,
and my slave anywhere.
I wish and he would just
recite the fifth amendment.
Let me put it yet one more way.
There is a certain element of honor.
It stinks here in the south about slavery.
Their moral stance comes from this belief,
this position,
and think about this in your own time.
The idea set in among northerners that
the legal status of slavery in the
Western territories stood as a measure
of its moral standing everywhere.
Let me repeat that.
Okay.
The legal standing of slavery
in the Western territory
stood as a measure of its
moral standing everywhere.
If you tell me slavery is wrong enough
that you will not have it in America's
future,
then you're telling me it's wrong where
I have it and I don't accept that and I
won't live in the same political
culture with you if I have to,
if I don't have to on that basis.
So why all the fuss?
I mean think today.
Think today about some of our
greatest salient, polarizing issues
at the risk of bringing them up.
If I were a gay American and I
believed in my right to be married,
I would believe that the legal status
of gay marriage in a Kansas where they
have a referendum is a measure
of its moral status everywhere
and extrapolate from there to other
issues. You outlaw who I am, what I do,
what I stand for in one state.
What are you saying about it in another,
oh, we shouldn't talk about the
president in history courses. I'm sorry.
The first is because it's really a debate
about America's future kind of future.
Would it have? Well, there
were four plans put in place,
and as these four plans are going
to come together around this debate,
over the compromise of 1850,
the first plan,
uh, these were all on your outline.
If you could see it earlier,
you want that backup.
Okay.
The first we call the Wilmot
proviso for good reason.
It's named for David Wilma,
well,
young Democratic Party representative
in the House of Representatives who in
1846 got up in the midst of the
Mexican, well, this is a Democrat now
and not a wig or a free soiler.
He's from Pennsylvania.
Any didn't particularly
care about black folks.
But he got up in the debates over
the Mexican war about, uh, about, uh,
provisions for the troops and all
those debates. And he said, okay,
we're going to war with Mexico.
But in any new territory we
gained from Mexico, slavery,
she'll never exist. It's as simple
as that. That's the Wilmot proviso.
It's a great trivia question.
If you have to ever have to play trivia
in a bar ass, what's the Wilmot Proviso?
Nobody knows.
But it was the rallying cry of
the free soil movement. Okay,
a war. We're going to get
millions of acres of territory.
Slavery will never exist.
This was the free soil formula.
The language was borrowed
from the northwest door news,
all but one northern state
legislature endorsed it. All.
Southern legislatures condemned it.
Ge,
a little harbinger of things come there
perhaps at first passed the House of
Representatives and the first try 83 to
64 rep reflecting that the house has far
more northern representatives because
the north has more population,
but it did not pass the Senate
where the slave states still have parody.
There was a good deal of racist support
for this will mount himself said,
well, I'll quote him here. You get this.
Free is free Labor ideology,
ideologies, a mixture of ideas.
This is Wilma in the debates.
I have no squeamish sensitiveness
upon the subject of slavery. Norm,
no morbid sympathy for the slave.
I plead the cause and
rights of White Freeman.
I would preserve to free white labor,
a fair country,
a rich inheritance where the sons of
toil of my own race and color can live
without the disgrace which association
with Negro Slavery Brings Upon Free
Labor,
doesn't get more direct than that.
Keep the West free of
slavery and black people
was really David wilmotts position.
The second possible plan
is what was known formally,
legally a state sovereignty.
This is the state's rights position.
This is the south position,
at least on this question,
the individual's constitutional right
of ownership and slaves as property and
transport of slaves as property.
State sovereignty.
States rights wasn't deed deeply at the
root of the south growing position here
that ultimately no federal legislature,
president,
no federal authority existed
to stop slavery's expansion.
The third position,
a very American position,
a natural outcome of the first two,
the first two mix like oil and water,
you need a compromise position
and that's popular sovereignty.
Popular sovereignty was not a new idea
in the midst of the Mexican war and its
aftermath and been around for awhile.
It was the simple idea that there
would be no act of Congress on this.
Take Congress out of the story and
simply let the people in the Western
territory have a vote. What?
I'm, have a referendum.
Let there be popular democracy.
If the people who settle Utah
when a vote to have slave labor,
then they vote for it. If they
don't, they don't. Democracy.
What could be better?
This had the wonderful kind of charm
of ambiguity is David Potter ones
beautifully put it a term of ambiguity.
It is kind of a place there for everybody.
As long as you trusted the democratic,
yeah,
but if you're going to
have that referendum,
the problem of course always
was when do you hold the vote?
Do you hold the vote early
in the territorial process
where to hold the vote laid
in the territory process?
Do you establish a rule?
There's gotta be a certain amount
of population before, excuse me,
before you hold that vote,
southerners,
one of that vote held late in the process
because it would give their system
longer to get there.
It would take a while.
If you're going to take 50 slaves out
to Kansas or Nebraska or further west,
it's going to take awhile for that
loan farmer in his Conestoga wagon.
He can get there quicker
and fourth they went back to
the old Missouri compromise.
It's the principle of
geographical division here.
It's the old principle
of geographical division.
The Missouri compromise of 1820 you
all learned this somewhere in school,
established the 36 30 parallel from the
Mississippi River to the Pacific Ocean
and it's said in 1820 a very important
act of Congress in 1820 in this store and
know to be so twisted and abused and
debated in the 1850s as a sacred act.
It said slavery shit would
never exist north of that line.
The problem was it half of California
was already north of that line.
Now a lot of people,
all right in the way we're going to head
this problem off now is just to keep,
keep drawing careful geographic
lines across the continent,
free soil above slave labor. Below. We'll
just, we'll just keep drawing that line.
All right.
I'm going to have to leave you hanging
here about the color from eyes itself.
That's fine cause we can
do the cut of promos.
It's collapsing lead right into
the Kansas Nebraska pro. Hold on,
I've got a minute.
I think the election of 1848 was crucial.
Democrats ran Lewis Cass of Michigan,
thoroughly forgettable politician.
I'm sure you've never heard of him,
but he was a great proponent
of popular sovereignty.
They run in a popular sovereignty
platform, the wet, the promise,
slavery in the West. Now there's whole
Mexican war problem. We'll solve it.
Popular Democracy,
the wigs run Zachary Taylor war,
hero of the Mexican war or rough and
ready problem was he was a Louisiana slave
holder
and out of this furor over the expansion
of slavery in the West came to new
political off shoots.
One was called the conscience Whigs.
They were created first in Massachusetts
and they gave us Charles, among others,
a group of abolitionists Wiggs
who broke with the Whig party.
Now it would never go back.
A harbinger of the ultimate death within
the next four years of the Whig party
and the other was the free soil party
born in the convention in Buffalo,
New York in 1848 it ran Martin van Buren
and I'd choice for president in 1848 a
former president,
they stood for one thing,
stopping at all costs,
the expansion of slavery
into America's West.
The free soilers took 10%
of the auto vote in 1848 election when
Zachary Taylor war hero was elected
and then gold was discovered
in California over night,
it seemed like it was overnight.
California was going to be
ready for statehood and Oh God,
what to do with it because if it comes
in as this free state or a slave state,
it's going to upset the balance
in the Senate in a setting,
huge territory out there
and suddenly there was a need, a desperate
need, threats coming from the south.
John C.
Calhoun is calling us southern convention
threats from some northerners who were
saying no on her all costs.
We will stop the expansion of slavery.
There's a need to fund
yet new Middle Ground.
A night in January,
teen 50 Henry Clay got together and
she washed down and a hell of a lot of
brandy with Daniel Webster.
And they cut a deal
that became the compromise of 1850.
I'll leave you hanging there.
Clay and Webster are drunk.
They're fashioning the great compromise,
or are they hoped it would save the union?
Clay at the end of that month would go
before the US Senate and announced the
five provisions of his compromise.
And in so doing,
he stood up and he held a piece of
the coffin of George Washington.
No, I don't know if it really was or not,
but it was a piece of the true cross, uh,
bowl piece of wood. This is from wash
George Washington's coffin. He said,
we must circle the wagons.
We must save the Union.
We must swallow this and do that.
And then we're grows.
And there were cheers.
People wept,
people shouted.
And people were really worried that
the union was going to unravel and fall
apart. And it almost did. So you.